this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by blue apron skip meal
planning and get straight to cooking
with blue apron enjoy delicious meals
that are great on the grill like honey
Chipotle glazed chicken with poblano and
lime rice and smoky depth to your dinner
while enjoying the warm weather and
getting those perfect grill marks with
incredible ingredients and chef designed
recipes blue apron lets you see the
power of what food can do so go check
out this week's menu and get your first
three meals free at blue apron dot-com
slash Congrats that's blue apron com /
Congrats to get your first three meals
of free blue apron a better way to cook
this episode is also brought to you by
the Cash Shop all the babies use the
cash app which is why it's the number
one finance app in the App Store and now
the cash card is more powerful than ever
with cash apps latest feature cash boost
download the cash app and get your free
cash card and select your boost save
money when you swipe on stuff like
coffee Chipotle Shake Shack and more
download the free cash app for iOS or
Android now congratulations
podcast let's do this first you can get
my app here and you can do the listen
first view 10 or so minutes of the
podcast every week live on my app that's
the only way you can do that live so you
can do that you can do you can download
it on what do you call it the iTunes
Store or wherever apps are available and
then also what you can do is get tickets
to see me in Montreal coming up go to my
website and I'm also coming to Kansas so
go check my the follow the leader tour
here it comes
to Canada and Kansas and Lincoln
Nebraska so those are the next dates
coming up
and watch a show we have called meetings
and I'm back from Houston I was in
Houston did six shows and they were
really really really fun man I love
performing in Houston a lot of people in
Texas when you say Houston they're like
nah man don't like it there because
there there's a really humid and [__]
but Houston is [__] awesome man I
love it
the crowds are great through only one
person out of let's see that would be
probably like 3,000 people so that's a
great ratio there was one girl and then
she got upset
and then sent me a nasty message and
then I posted it on Instagram and then
she apologized apparently not apparently
she did apologize so I took it down I'm
actually like that
because I feel like look I like roasting
people I like putting them on on blast
putting on the internet if they send me
something online I figure it's for
online you know so but I've posted stuff
and people have like been like oh can
you take it down and I take it down dude
unless you're being a [__] piece of
[__] then it's like go but I love
Houston it was way too hot there were no
boa constrictors there which was odd
because of how hot it was it's like too
hot it's actually too hot to go even in
the pool cuz then you're like outside
you just go outside and you're like oh
[__] I'm gonna [__] get cancer
immediately
because of the [__] shoulders getting
all red and such I worked out dude I
stayed at this place called the
Houstonian which first of all that name
you know like how much of a [__] do you
have to be to name something Houstonian
like it's [__] so ancient it was made
in 1980 hair at the Houstonian and of
course did you oh dude did you want to
guess if they had painted buffalo on the
and painted deer paintings on the walls
did you want to guess if they had
painted game on the walls of this hotel
oh you don't have to guess oh because
in Texas Oh cuz it's called the
Houstonian oh um yeah so we stayed there
and this place was like a resort
or some [__] I don't even know but it
was like the gym there was I told my
travel agent I was like get a place with
a good gym and it was the biggest gym
ever and it was awesome
but like this is what the gym had in a
hotel it had [__] basketball courts
which my opener [__] play basketball
on it was terrible posted a picture of
him doing an air ball he shoots multiple
air balls and then it has a really like
one of the biggest weight rooms I've
ever seen and then it has a rock
climbing [__] part a cafeteria this
is all in the Sports Center
then it has I think it has what is the
not handball what is the [__]
racquetball ah then it has so many
jerseys and [__] like up on the walls
and what people frame jerseys do it
that's [__] weird frame things that
are paper only uh-huh and then also
there was a track around the whole gym
dude like that [__] moms would run on
and it was a healthy mix of moms you
know kids and I'm gonna add another
weight room that was just for residents
or I don't know what the [__] this deal
dude how about when you go stay at some
hotels and it's on your leg up and
they're like no this is the wrong
entrance this is for residents what are
you talking about dude what it's a
[__] hotel or an apartment building
don't mash them together you have
separate ones the W hotels do that a lot
they're like it's like out the W the W
the W Hotel [__] we residents dude I
wouldn't like that just living at a
hotel you can get room service there too
you know it's like weird
you can live imagine living in a place
where you can get room service what do
you [__] richy-rich it's like you've
an on-call Butler and they make your
room up
probably everyday I don't know that's
[__] weird dude I don't I don't I
don't want the same maid coming in to
clean my room that's gonna clean a bunch
of different people that I don't like
room right next to me that are touching
now I have a cleaning lady that's fine
but like I don't know who she works with
besides me but I know they're far away
she doesn't [__] what my neighbors did
and I found her right so if my neighbors
were like I'm gonna use her to that's
fine but I'm not gonna use yours if
you're right next to me it's weird as
[__]
somebody's look is saying on my app can
you frame metals man you know just frame
whatever you want really okay I'm just
saying don't take anything I say is the
[__] gospel
I [__] lit this dude up on Twitter
today I was just bored on a flight I go
too far I think I go too far cuz the
thing is people here's what the thing is
people think just by looking at me that
I'm a bro that I drank a lot that I
[__] to snort coke and [__] your girl
and that I was in a frat but like
nothing could be further from the truth
basically a douche right they don't know
me I'm so far from that but then what
happens is somebody will [__] say
something to me on Twitter like yo you
[__] douche you suck whatever and
then I'll [__] you know naturally the
boy claps back cuz he's gotta cuz he's a
human cuz he claps back
is he better than that no he's that good
and then what happens is I to the people
don't know me they see those responses
then I look like the person is making me
out to be in the first place which fine
I have trouble caring but then I think I
I end up going too far sometimes but I
don't usually delete the tweets because
I feel like that's me dog you know it's
some it's I've definitely deleted tweets
but like it's there's more it's more
[__] to delete tweets like like I think
Trump is deleted tweets and it's like
yeah you're the president you don't
delete
it's [__] stand by what you said but
this guy clap said something about like
I said how are Kelly's music sucks
anyway and thank God now that he [__]
is like a piece of [__] and we all know
it like we can just not pretend like his
music is good anymore and then this guy
is like it's time for white guys to be
band on talking about black music and
it's like okay so you're racist and then
people are like oh racism doesn't exist
for white people okay man okay that's
fine dude hey just say everything all
the time and then and then I said and
then I just was retweeting what he was
saying not even saying anything about it
and then people were like clapping back
at him and then he was like upset and
saying [__] like [__] whatever dude
your comedy is shitty and I didn't even
say anything about him and I was like
dude I'm just this is you man I'm
ruining what you're saying and then I
started to light him up and he was like
he was like oh it bother bother
obviously bothers you and I was like now
the thing is I'm gonna forget about this
in three minutes but you're gonna
remember this forever
it was like no I'm not and I was like do
it and I didn't even mean it in a
douchey way I'm just like listen man
I'm [__] all over social media I'm on
I'm on TV by the way you wrote me now
I'm gonna come up in your [__]
suggested [__] ye idiot
okay then also I'm on Netflix all the
time like there's plenty of me out there
every time you see me you're gonna think
of getting [__] flayed oh you got
grill marks and he got grill marks I
want to make that that shirt like the
got milk got grill marks dude there
isn't an ad campaign that I am more
resentful for but then the got milk [__]
that got milk ad was one of the greatest
ads in advertising history but everybody
stop ripping it off with your stupid
[__] window cleaning service do you
know what I mean got dirt got
did we I saw a religious one that was
like God God it was like what dude
Spacek snot trying slay Z so um so
anyway so yeah I don't know I think yeah
I go too far but like it's like you made
your bed laying it to Twitter is Twitter
it's just what it is I don't know I
don't [__] care enough I don't care
if somebody thinks I'm [__] douchey I
don't that's right you can't control how
people now I know people will argue with
that I think that you can't control how
people are gonna see you and and and and
people will be like no but you can but
the second you try controlling how
people see you is the second you're
being a fake ass mark [__]
[__] dude yeah be real be Ridge it's
free conch but be Ridge the second you
start to think about oh this is how I've
got to be so people know that I'm a good
guy what you are is paper cutout which R
is Ken I'm not Ken dude I'm not Ken I
don't have a [__] glossed over [__] I
have a [__] [__] and balls
I'm not wearing khakis and a Hawaiian
shirt I'm not driving around with a girl
in a pink car I'm not plastic I'm Chris
D'Elia or cristela as the guy at the
airport said hey oh my god cristela
sometimes I go daliyah but thanks that's
it dude you know mini clap backs mini
mini uh none unfuckin hurting clap backs
under not just like little toss lobby
clap backs you know hey Chris Delilah
D'Elia thanks keep walking
little little short little clap back not
even a [__] clap back that's gonna
hurt your day nice guy clap back I can
do a nice guy clap back it's like saying
actually
right anybody says actually is a [__]
raging [__] actually I got something
else for you you say something hey you
know the [__] this is the biggest
desert actually that's actually not the
biggest desert you know the big desert
is this but yeah man that's what it
that's that's uh so that's so anyway how
to [__] clap back you gotta be you
gotta be who you gotta be and it's hard
though it really is hard to be who you
got who you have to be because you have
to grow as a person you can't just come
out on level 100 man you come out you
don't even know how to walk
you [__] exit your mom's [__] and
you don't even know how to say can I
have a grilled cheese right even if you
want one you don't even know what a
[__] grilled cheese is you don't even
know what cheese is let alone grilling
it on bread you you don't even know what
taste is when you come out you're on
level zero and then you become right and
then you become what you become but what
you become isn't ever what you become
because you're never done becoming and
then you die right there that's who you
are
that's who you are the guy does second
before you die that's who you are right
here this is who you are right here or
that's who you are
or maybe we should that's who you are
huh
who's that guy that's who you are right
there in that last second it's kind of
high up here huh that's who you are and
that's who you've become so so everybody
has been this guy who's been too far
everybody and that's where apologies
come in and say whoops you know I wasn't
that guy I'm not that guy anymore in
addition it than that and I'm growing
you know and I'm trying to be who the
[__] I'm I'm I am the second before I
die but you never know when that's going
to be anyway
so you know you think about the thing
like the like the [__] like the James
gun thing man
and you know the director of guardians
of the galaxy which is now he's not the
director of the third guardians of
galaxy because people brought up old
tweets that he had that were absolutely
jokes now granted they were not good
jokes okay but he was trying to make
jokes he didn't mean any of it a lot of
his jokes were about pedophilia and you
know transgender people and that's you
know they were just off-color and not
not funny enough I mean I think you
could joke about anything as long as
it's funny enough but it did just
weren't that funny and I think I think
he knows that and he's expressed that
and he apologized for the tweets uh uh I
think years later I think years ago
rather and now and by the way I feel
like Disney knew about that early years
ago and now some guy drudges up these
old tweets they go viral and now Disney
is like oh never mind
he can't be he can't he can't direct
guardians of galaxy 3 because of what he
said when they know damn well what he
said dude these guys vet everybody you
think Disney you think [__] companies
like Target and Universal and McDonald's
they don't vet [__] they vet
[__] they have people whose
jobs are to [__] look up people's
names on Twitter and online and all that
[__] man they knew about it and now
they're gonna fire him why because he
said this [__] or because the [__]
angry mob on Twitter came after him and
that's not okay that's not okay dude
because then you're giving in to what
the [__] people want and then you're
censoring and you're letting people
dictate who you can hire rather than
dude those movies were [__] awesome
those guardians of the galaxy movie he
found out who he was with those movies
man he was pushing the envelope trying
to find out to be you know a lot of guys
do this [__] you see it with [__]
comedians all the time you see in
particular with it with women comedian
coming up
they got to talk about their [__]
because they want to shock people they
want to be like I'm gonna talk about
this just because I'm a woman I'm gonna
break stereotypes I'm gonna talk about
my [__] on stage because I can write
and then they find out who they really
are on stage and not all their jokes are
about [__] now a lot of them are
because that's a [__] funny subject
all right but you know a lot of guys go
on stage and they start they talk they
think it's funny to do be dark or a real
[__] comic and they talk about
pedophilia and [__] and it's just not
that funny dude and they become who
they're gonna become but you have to
allow them to become that person and
James Gunn found out who he was and he's
a [__] director that directs good
funny action superhero movies and he
probably does other good [__] too
I'm such an idiot I don't know I don't
know about directors but like he you
know and now he's fired he can't do it
because of what the the [__] [__]
trolled up and that's really not [__]
okay
and it's okay to apologize you know if
you want to but man dude if I was in his
position I'm not like the guy who's like
don't apologize if you want to apologize
apologize dude if you hurt somebody's
feeling feelings and you feel and and if
it feels bad for you then then go for it
man I don't particularly get when
comedians apologize but he's not a
comedian so you know if he feels like he
was out of his element shouldn't have
done that [__] but for me dude if
somebody wants an apology for what I say
some [__] on stage you can go [__]
yourself man go change the world how
about that go change the [__] world I
mean for real dude [__] you [__] I'm
trying to [__] I'm trying to figure
out who the [__] I am on stage and joke
around and it has to be a safe space
talk about your safe space that's where
it has to be [__] safe go [__] your
College go [__] your college I don't
give a [__] man
be upset and and you know what call me
privileged call me whatever the [__] I
it fine go ahead
I want to tweet a picture of my dick so
it's out there I mean I've actually
never sent a dick pic to anybody I maybe
have to like Bryan Callen or some [__]
but yeah man
I don't know it's a [__] weird weird
weird weird weird weird world you have
to be who you are from jump otherwise
people are going to [__] murder you
they want you to be at level 100 when
you come out the [__] and that's not
who they are so how the [__] can we be
that we're all holding someone else to a
high to the highest [__] standard
when you got [__] bone you got bones
in your closet man you got bones in your
[__] closet [__] you [__]
then then people get so mad when you
[__] clap back but whatever I don't
know it's Twitter dude it's free [__]
what do you want man
you know these [__] are you're
sampling [__] at Whole Foods like no I
don't like that one do you have it more
like that dude put it in your mouth and
[__] swallow it straight if you're
eating something off a toothpick you be
goddamn happy with it anyway didn't mean
to get so heated but that's what this
podcast is it's a [__] you know you
get on and we just start going and
nobody's driving I know I say I'm the
[__] cult leader here but no one's
driving this we're on a roller coaster
on a [__] we're in outer space
floating around dude without that thing
connected the tether connected you know
in every movie they do it like that and
they [__] have the tether every space
movie they have the guy who links onto
the tether and then they go and they
took try and fix the spacecraft and it's
like holidays it's how they're gonna
break and the tether always breaks and
they're like how they gonna get back and
sometimes they do and sometimes they
don't they die and sometimes they live
but you know what it's all good oh yeah
a cig enough dude this is crazy to me I
don't know if I've talked about this on
the podcast before another guy have but
this is something I've thought about for
years like okay I think like this
sexuality and homosexuality is like a
scale right and like you can you you
know you you know there's a guy out
there on the let's say the left side you
know just picking an arbitrary side here
that is the straightest guy the most
heterosexual guy never in any realm of
any possibility would want to have sex
with another guy okay then on the other
end right there's the gayest guy and he
would never under any circumstance
everyone to have sex with a girl right
okay
in between is where pretty much
everybody falls right that's what I
think you know you got guys who are like
like like me I've never thought about
having sex with a girl never wanted to I
never thought about having sex to the
guy never wanted to I've often thought
about having sex with girls but I'm you
know uh you know I don't know if I was
in prison for [__] eight days maybe
I'd be like god I've gotta do it gotta
do it right here's the here's the thing
that just really gets me [__] thinking
and I'm a dumb [__] okay I'm I'm a dumb
dummy and I'm uneducated here alright so
this is coming from a guy who's a dumb
dummy and AH an uneducated a guy doesn't
look like a girl okay a guy also doesn't
look like a [__] chair alright but a
guy looks way more like a girl than a
chair
alright now if an alien came down and
was like group these [__] things
group two of these things together and
they a guy girl and a chair anyone would
be like put the guy and the girl
together the other one doesn't fit right
that's how much a guy looks like a girl
a lot when you throw a chair in there
okay now I don't want to have sex with a
girl a [__] guy god what the [__]
you're distracting me with the [__] I
don't want to have sex with a guy as
much as
don't want to have sex with a chair but
how's that possible
right cuz guys kind of look like girls
and if you look at it in that way you
know they got legs in a button [__] you
can [__] it girls got it too even
feminine looking guys I don't want to
[__] those guys either as much as I
don't want to [__] a chair how is that
possible I don't I'm too dumb to talk
about that I think there's some like I
think some scientists should work on
that
like they should get a guy and a girl in
a chair and like put a guy in the room
and then see what happens you know what
probably happened the guy the other guy
probably just [__] the guy and the
girl back yeah get up and then they'd
[__] beat the [__] out of him it
would probably some weird what's that
move was that movie or the documentary
that they made with a guy's pretended
they were Nazis and then really became
Nazis or whatever the [__] you know I'm
talking about that [__] movie the
there's something effect what is it the
the [__] was that movie I it'll bothers
me I know the listeners are ahead of me
right now they're like oh I know what
it's called but they can't tell me it's
like it was like to document my brother
was just talking about this it's not an
oxy Nazi documentary it was called the
this something with an A effect [__]
it not saying Nazis not going to bring
it up you see once again one farce
googling the completely wrong [__] it
was the whatever they put guys in a Cell
and it was a ploy it was it was a in an
acting exercise some of the guys were
guards and some of the guys were not
guards and they made a movie about it
too like an actual movie and it's like
the prison experiments and like that
anyway and they were like you guys were
in charge you guys aren't and in like
[__] 20 minutes they were like yeah
[__]
pieces of [__] get down there you maggot
you know Stanford Prison Experiment
that's what it was right yeah
like that's crazy by the way I was
trying to figure out what the [__] that
was for so long I don't know even why I
brought it up but I brought it up so
let's roll with it dude that's a crazy
[__] thing that that is a crazy thing
you know what we all think we all try to
like think no I would never do that
that's not what I would do there's no
way no way if I were in that situation I
would do this but you just don't know
right you don't know because the only
thing that's happened to you is what's
happened to you do it you didn't live
these other [__] like hundreds
and thousands of years ago people would
like well if I think it's yeah it's not
happens in [__] certain parts of the
world they cut the [__] clips off of
women it's like what the [__] man that's
insane
hey don't do that but they think it's
totally normal they think it's what's
right you know and we like to think oh
if we were in that we were growing up we
would know that that's wrong but dude
what
maybe not dude no way you're just a
private product of your environment man
wow that's [__] and you've got to
start to try you got to try at least
come out on level 100 bro we're [__]
I'm gonna do the reads here blue apron
blue apron delivers fresh pre-portioned
ingredients and step-by-step recipes
right to your door that can be cooked in
under 45 minutes the menu changes every
week based on what's in season and is
designed by blue aprons in-house
culinary team it offers 12 new recipes
each week and customers can pick two or
three or four recipes based on what best
fits our schedule blue apron is awesome
man I eat it all the time I I still have
yet to have a bad meal or even a subpar
meal I just think that it's great they
put great stuff in there it it's all
healthy and it feels good to eat and it
tastes really great upcoming meals
honey Chipotle glazed chicken with
poblano and lime rice a sweet chili beef
and vegetable stir-fry with garlic rice
that's a customer favorite barbecue
vegetable flatbread with Swiss cheese so
check out this week's menu and get your
first three meals at blue apron Dom /
Congrats that's blue apron got blue
apron calm
/ congrats to get your first three mills
free blue apron a better way to cook the
chances are you've heard about this
thing called honey it's the free browser
add-on that finds and applies the best
promo codes every time you shop it
honestly kind of sounds too good to be
true but it's not it's great first you
are probably wondering how much money
can oh honey really save me turns out
honey has already saved people over 800
million dollars and maybe you're
thinking the honey doesn't work on sites
that I shop at the truth is honey works
on over 30,000 sites even Amazon so you
go there all the time and I go there
almost only but the big question is how
is honey free what's the catch there's
no catch
honey gets a small commission from sites
where honey saves you money so it's not
on you and it's always free 10 million
customers trust honey to save the money
every day I bought some sheets at
macys.com
actually and save 20% I didn't have to
do anything and that's just by clicking
in this honey thing it's very easy and
it's awesome there's no reason not to
use it it's always free and it takes
just two clicks to install and honey all
you got to do is add it to your browser
for free right now at join honeycomb /
Congrats that's join honey calm /
Congrats yeah so what I was trying to
say is I don't wanna [__] chairs did
it's so hot in Houston you it's like you
don't go outside for more than a second
as soon as you get outside it sucks man
I was listening to that new r.kelly song
though that 19 minute go [__] yourself
song are Kelly make a [__] two and a
half minutes song what are you doing he
sucks dude he [__] sucks I mean that
the trapped in a closet for funny and
novelty reasons was funny and I used to
be like ah dude this is the biggest
badass [__] in history just cuz he did
it but like he at that song he sucks
dude I mean his music [__] sucks
donkey balls
and the new one is the actual worst one
I listened to two minutes of that 19
minute song and I was just holy [__] for
Christ's sake I was listening to it in
the car on the way to the airport and I
was like this song I said it to mark and
Mike my openers and I got out of car and
the driver came around gave me my
backpack and he was like hey can I ask
you a question I was like what's up and
he was like do you mind if I ask you
what song you were listening to and I
was like oh that's the new art Kelly
song and he said ok thanks and then he
walked around back to his driver side
door and as I was walking out he said
that songs that songs awesome and I said
what and he said that's a great song and
I went uh-huh yeah I didn't know if he
was trying to be like watch I I didn't
know what he was trying to do and maybe
he was it seemed too calculated to just
the way he did it seemed to calculate it
to be like oh I really wanna know what
that song is cuz it sounds good but I
don't know maybe I don't know I'm white
and the driver was black maybe he was
thinking like all this white guy doesn't
know about black musically the [__]
guy who tweeted me but I don't know I
don't know what it was but it was weird
and then but then on top of that have
you heard the song dude let me just play
a little bit of it I guess I'll play on
a computer Oh like Google I can just do
it on Google or whatever or YouTube it
works
oh yeah yeah it works you have a rose
playing done wife Matt Cobra oh wow or
Kelly admit it it's called hey man you
did it you know so it's called I admit
it I you know what bother you it's all
about him admitting [__] it's like it's
so annoying that people think because
artists when they're being honest like
it's taken this [__] stupid turn
where it's like oh it's on people like
just like honesty like it also has to be
artistic people are like yeah but he
just
aired his soul I don't give a [__] is it
good
a lot of people do with comedy like
they're like uh yeah but he's he's
honest and he's he's being he's opening
up he's being vulnerable dude I don't
give a [__] make it [__] funny you
know like just be funny beasts that's
why I like [__] silly [__]
I'm not trying to bring it to comedy but
did this is what it is on the thing are
Kelly I admit and then impress these 19
minutes song talking about everything
Syd not a good [__] promo like he
does stuff like I admit I made mistakes
I admit it's so hard to focus
I admit yada yada and then like I like
after the second minute I stop listen
because it got like it got like he's the
victim you know he's like I admit I have
people around me that [__] up you know I
admit I trust too much it's like dude if
you're gonna [__] be vulnerable just
keep it to your [__] self [__] I
admit that sometimes I go to the wrong
restaurants and they don't they're not
timely with my order
I admit I should be better at picking my
restaurants also his voice is kinda okay
you know there's like the best singer at
any High School in America is better
than him
heck you don't I mean also his lyrics
[__] basic I admit I admit sometimes
when I go car shopping
I get the vehicle with the wrong package
and the car salesman shouldn't have sold
me sold it to me he hid information from
me I admit I've been here I have been
hidden I've had information hidden from
me and acted with what I thought was
correct
I didn't go to classes I admit that I
dropped out of school I admit that I
dropped out of school he says yeah all
right man you can google that oh how
brave dude thanks r.kelly thanks for
admitting that you dropped out of school
because that makes the world better and
then also thanks so much for letting
kids think it will be okay to drop out
of school after you maybe peed on them
ah just this how long the song should be
four seconds I met I pissed on 14 year
olds Brown
that's it credits I admitted I had a sex
code Brown that's it by the way I don't
think that's that bad I'm trying to get
one sex cult admit I just don't feel
like trying but all my building goes
round me keep telling the girls about
that you darling
[__] with a couple of fans I admit I'm a
gift and the curse oh my god dude I
admit I'm a gift and a curse dude what
are you Batman what did that one just
say hello I'm now just gonna read it
what did it that one says they dude the
one up there about pedophilia I saw I
mean so long he's scrolling so far to
get took his long
I admit I [__] with all the ladies
that's both older and young ladies it is
yeah I have to write in parenthesis I
love always how they put the [__] in the
princes you don't have to do that
he said it just put it there too but
tell me how they call it pedophile
because that [__] is crazy oh well okay
I'll explain it I'll explain it dude if
you [__] someone under well let's just
be conservative seventeen I think that's
the lowest it goes in America and you're
your age then you would call it
pedophilia because well it's pedophilia
it's like looking at a sandwich and
calling it a sandwich that's why so
that's why so you're a [__] idiot
um I mean pedophilia sexual feelings
directed toward children good thing one
fire looked at up to now it's on my IP
address oh it's sunny okay whatever well
one fire is gonna be [__] one put in
prison soon what else is there good ones
that you've seen all right there what's
that I mean what does that even mean
oh wow look at this I did that bump and
grind I did that 12-play I did that fed
up I changed the damn game so I deserve
me a fair play so put some respect on my
name fair this is his home
oh the this how you know the songs too
long all right first of all it says
verse six okay too long have three
mostly have two if you got a good song
three on a very rare occasion if you got
a banger four but not really because the
DJ could just replay this song if you
got a banger but this is verse six like
it's the Book of Revelations okay this
guy writes I had this guy sings I I
admit I love Steve Harvey bye dude
that's what you go I admit it I love
Steve Harvey bye you don't have to admit
you love Steve Harvey
I admit I love Steve Harvey John Legend
and Tom Joyner who's that even the last
guy is a baseball player this guy i
admit i love john olerude i admit i love
handlee Mullins I made it I love Warren
Moon they're doing good in their lives
right now why would they want to tear
down another brother why are they trying
to do that maybe they're trying to do
that women show black men some love cuz
black men we go through enough oh dude
yeah alright that's true
but don't take your pedophilia and
[__] compare it to what to the black
struggle dude oh I'm a white guy I can't
talk about that
okay fine but I am that's ridiculous
dude that's [__] ridiculous
and anybody who he tricks with that I
get in a [__] get in the drawing
machine you know tumble around for a
little bit get your brain all [__]
bottled up change it around so the [__]
you thinking about
god that's so funny hey the songs over I
admit I love Steve Harvey you don't have
to that's not an admission you could
just say if you ever say oh dude I admit
I love Steve Harvey no you're just
saying it you're not admitting [__]
I admit I fondled a girl that's the end
of the song
the end playing Brown that's it that's
it it's a [__] 10-second song oh my
god Spotify took me off they playlist
they you know unbelievable
they don't want me to shine women's
group my god now don't get it twisted I
do support them but why they want to
bring down our ha
did you can't be vulnerable and call
yourself the r if your real name is
Robert dude [__] our Kelly dude [__]
that mother is this a good one two right
here three here hey you just Highland
[__] for no reason anyway dude how about
that 6-9 Rainbow Brite guy that got
[__] pistol-whipped and stole money
dude these guys what are they doing what
are they doing they're bragging about
all the [__] they have they're getting
kidnapped because of that hat
that's so weird this world man I'll do
more reads here and then I talk about
six nine post mates as usual your
stomach and the rest of your life read
war you need to eat but you can't stop
what you're doing to deal with it ah you
know I hate doing that the only fast
things that deliver are not what you
want right well post mates changed all
that
the app it is
the app that adds a delivery option to
your favorite restaurants it'll go get
your food anywhere you want imagine
anything you want to eat delivered you
don't have to drive park or even talk on
the phone to order you just download the
app 24 hours a day 365 days a year
post mates will bring what you want
within the hour it's great I use it I
mean almost daily you could see where
your food is and track your driver so if
you're impatient you can just look and
be like Oh keys right there relax you
forget your eggs and milk no problem
craving a tasty burger check looking for
the perfect bottle of red wine or a
summer beer order up post mates is your
new long-term munchies booty call for
limited time post mates is giving you
$100 of free delivery credit for your
first 7 days to start your free
deliveries download the app today and
use code Congrats
that's code Congrats Co ngr 80s for the
idiots and you get $100 of free delivery
credit for your first 7 days save the
hassle get the food you love fast at
post mates with code Congrats
Square cash if you haven't heard we're
switching the cat we're switching to the
cash app I didn't buy you know it's the
number one ranked app in the finance
department and you got to know that
because you listen this show me said all
the time and it lets you do the most
with your money you want to pay people
back by cell Bitcoin put your paycheck
into their act into the app directly or
order a free custom cash card spent
anywhere to spend anywhere you like and
now the cash card is more powerful than
ever with cash apps latest feature cash
boost the cash cards boost a program
lets you get instant discounts every
time you swipe your card right now you
can get a dollar off every purchase you
make it coffee shops across the country
when you pay with your cash card it
doesn't stop there it has 15% off
discounts a lot of other cool places you
like to go to Chipotle Shake Shack more
I also could follow you can also follow
cash app on Twitter and Instagram to
find out where the booths are next so
let me save money like that go get
boosted download the cash app your free
cash card and select your boost of
course when you download the cash app
and two rewards code Congrats
five dollars goes to you and five
dollars goes to time's up leave a legal
defense fund download the free cash app
for iOS or Android now
but yeah the 6-9 guy our sorry Rainbow
Brite is what I'm gonna call him he he
just [__] I don't know these rappers
it's weird it's rude ah so it would it's
weird what social media does to every
industry and everybody but [__] hip
hop is just the thing that's just been
the most crazy cuz it turned a most of
hip hop into a joke
you know I'm not talking about guys that
are legit like NAS or Pusha T but these
guys these pink haired guys and these
guys who aren't about the music they're
about the shell of it you know that's
why I say what you want about Drake you
know he's number one so he gets a lot of
the hate out there you know he's the
biggest selling artist but like people
hate on him because he's number one but
dude he he he at least he's [__]
about the music dude I like his music so
whatever but these [__] are
just it nobody listens to them because
the music they listen to them because of
their outlandish behavior which is like
dude be a [__] comedian be Tom Green
dude like what do you know nobody's
about to music there's a few people
about the music rather and I know you
can't get it's way easier to get
successful if you're not just about the
music like look at little palm look at
6-9 look at these [__] guys but he
was hospitalized after reportedly being
kidnapped and robbed and I just love how
I heard that like he told the cops a
different thing than what he told social
media which is like he has to upkeep his
image how do [__] rappers do that it
must be exhausting to always have to be
that hard you know like especially if
you're one of those rappers that's like
mother [__] I'm praying always you're
always I play a [__] it's like
play sometimes though dude how about
that but like do these guys go to
literally literally are carrying around
[__] tens of thousands of dollars
sometimes $100,000 and going into a
jewelry place and just buying watches
and chains and [__] teeth and rings
and then
they get pistol-whipped and robbed and
it's like yeah no [__] dude of course
you're gonna get [__] pistol-whipped
and Rob don't don't do that
irresponsible [__] or do and that's
fine that's the life is getting they
gonna live
I guess you lost like a hundred thousand
dollars or something [__] crazy I was
at this place in Texas but people live
in a weird [__] mental space like I
was in this place in Texas I forget what
it's called but and they had like a
bunch of these signs that were like
these really cool signs that were like
aluminum or whatever you'd call them
they look like those you know for like
advert signs and [__] and there was
outside on the side of the building and
I was like I was like I asked I was like
the waitress I was like that's [__]
that'd take like how do you they don't
people to steal those and she was like I
don't think so she's like nah nobody
steals and she I was like really
those begun in a [__] second in LA
that closed down they big they closed
down the minute after the close to be
gone and then and then she was like I
feel like people who would steal
wouldn't wouldn't steal those things cuz
the thing the people who want those
things already have money because those
are things that people with money buy
and I was like oh the worst logic of all
time huh like just the [__] that flies
out of people's mouths they just say
[__] they just don't care they're just
like nosing your [__] I don't need to
think about it I have other assets
besides this talking thing
it's so weird when people are like that
I spend my time thinking about [__] by
myself you know like when somebody comes
up to me and it was like what do you
think about this I already have a
[__] idea because I've thought about
something like it but I think that's
what comes with being a comedian you
know you think about a bunch of [__]
already because you want you know you
want to you want to uh have a person uh
what do you call it an opinion on a lot
of things because you want to have a
perspective in it in case you need to be
funny in any [__] moment on stage you
know and I admit that so put that in
your Kelly song I admit I've thought
about lots of things before in case
people won't ask me oh my god dude
people came after me after that heart
what art well a--quite are Kelly tweet
we were in an uber my buddies Irish and
he was with us his name's Mark I always
tell you about him but we were in an
uber and he was like and the girl who
picked us up was like first of all it
said a civic was gonna pick us up and
then like one of those boxy [__] cars
who whose idea was it to make cars boxy
do you know it's like that's just too
much development right that's like it's
like one of those movies in Hollywood
were like they should have [__] don't
do reshoots basically with the boxy car
when I look at them I don't do reshoots
but yeah it was whatever one of those
[__] boxy cars that they thought was
gonna be a good idea and now people
still have them just because they were
popular
well not popular but like they were a
thing a little bit of a thing in like
2003 in March and so it said a civic was
gonna come but this boxy [__] came
and I was like she was like Chris and I
was like yeah yeah I sorry you could
have a different car and she's like oh
yeah it didn't change over yet and I was
like okay let's get in and then we were
driving and then she was like where are
you from where are you from
like any time uber or any drivers
drivers start to make conversation with
me I always hit my [__] opener and
I'm like yo you answer these questions
you know
like if they're like so where you from
and Mike's on his phone I'll go and I'll
be like oh la and but yeah what are you
doing out here another girl you know
just hanging I'm like I'm so happy he's
right here just to [__] talk for me
man small talk asked [__] you
know no and and so mark answered instead
of Mike and Mark from Ireland so she's
like were you guys visiting from and he
was like Ireland and I was like well I'm
just gonna let it ride because I'm not
gonna be like oh [__] actually I'm
from LA and if she's not gonna be like
what about you guys she probably assumes
a role from Ireland so now we're from
Ireland no matter what happens I got a
[__] respond like an Irish guy or
whatever the [__] so hopefully he
doesn't ask me [__] so she's like oh wow
really a long trip for what just for fun
and he was like oh yeah which not true
we came for work and she was like well
how long you in town for and he said
tomorrow and he says oh that's a quick
trip yeah and then she was like just
kept asking questions usually so what
have you guys been doing and he was like
oh just you know eating hanging out just
like some good restaurants there's I go
we went to Chipotle in Starbucks and she
was like what there's good restaurants
out here and he was like what those are
good and she's like but you're there
anywhere and he's like what do you mean
what do you mean
and she was like there's tons of them he
says oh no I went to Starbucks and she
was like that's everywhere and he's like
oh there's more of them like he's
[__] with her and then I started to
like get into it you know and she was
like what do you mean yeah they're
everywhere and he's like oh I thought
there was just the one we asked the guy
for a local coffee shop and he's told us
Starbucks was he [__] with us and she
was like yeah yes he was like oh man we
really man we really liked it you know
we kept going back there and and then
she was like you don't have them in
Ireland and he said and he said no no I
thought it was just I don't know I
thought it was a mom-and-pop shop and he
was like and she pointed to and she was
like really
he was like yeah and then she's like so
what have you been doing and she said
and he said oh we just every night we
ask the door guy were to go
and uh he always sends us to a different
club or bar and it uh every time the we
look around and it's pretty much a gay
bar and we're looking for women though
and she was like oh really
and she was like well she's like Houston
is the second biggest gay population in
America and we were just like uh no it's
not just saying [__] you know he was
like oh really okay and he dropped she
dropped us off at this place and we just
kind of [__] I was only eight with
the [__] signs and [__] but uh yeah
it was funny man I don't normally like
that kind of humor but it was funny dude
cuz like weird is all and with the Irish
[__] no and then I and then when I said
bye I was like oh thanks a lot I did it
Irish because I was like I don't want to
[__] I want her to think we were
[__] with her but he was like he put
one over on her she definitely didn't
doesn't listen to this podcast so that's
okay ah it's crazy how gullible people
are though oh yeah by the way I only got
told this part isn't this is touring the
pockets but last time I was in Houston I
I was like doing my show and immediately
I had to like go to the bathroom in the
middle of my set oh this is this [__]
[__] actually I had to go I guess I
didn't tell Mike and Mark about this but
I had to go I was on stage and in the
middle I was like I think I got a speed
up through my set but I was halfway
through and I was like there's no way I
cannot [__] I can speed through it
this hard I still have like 30 minutes
left and I was like [__] I got to stop
because also my stomach was like look
and my [__] was like prepare to
unload and it got a little looser and I
was like a little alone and I literally
said to the crowd I was like hey guys um
hey man and I looked at the manager and
he's like what's up I was like can you
get Jason back out here this was a
[__] year and a half ago when I was
at last I Houston and my buddy Jason
Collins was opening for me and he was
like and
Jason came I was like what's up dude and
I was like yeah you gotta [__] do
some stand-up for like 10 minutes I
gotta go take a [__] and everyone's like
what and I was like dude I don't know
what to tell you I just gotta take a
[__]
and he came onstage he was like for real
and he was laughing everyone was
laughing I was like yeah I'll be back
guys be back in a little bit went to the
green room a little got it all out okay
and then came back and I was like dude
guys sorry I feel so much better let's
do this got right back into my act and
[__] did it you know and it was fine
I obviously made fun of it my letter it
was funny it was a special [__]
experience for that moment it so then
this weekend I did a bit worm I held my
eyes open for way too long in some
really well-written crafted comedy and
as a joke obviously Jack and and my
contact just all of a sudden went in the
back of my eye you know when that
happens
well you're like ah [__] that might be
there for just until I die you know and
you're like what the [__] but I had no
mirror I tried to look I was like guys
my [__] contacts in my brain right
now and I'm trying to look in a selfie
camera and there and like and I was like
you [__] a lot you know what's the
knowing thing is a lot of you guys are
gonna think this is a bit I'm doing
which is so stupid well it's not funny
why would I do it anyway I did the rest
of the [__] show with like 30 minutes
left with one eye being able to see and
the other one I went back into the
bathroom and then found it in the back
of my eye put it back put it back and
then when I came back to do like some of
the meet-and-greet pics that people
bought people were like some people were
like we're you serious or was that like
were you joking and I'm like not only is
it not funny
I'll just be able to tell first besides
the fact that it's not funny also be
able to tell what's a joke and what's
not a joke and what up what is a put on
him what's not a put on and then when I
say you guys are gonna think this is a
bit it's annoying cuz it's not a bit I'm
really [__] up here uh
then no it's not a bit people are still
like was it a bad furlough dude but
while I did that I didn't tell my sin I
didn't realize I haven't I didn't tell
Mike and Mark my [__] story so while
that was happening while I was on stage
I was talking about contact the manager
was like oh by the way guys do you know
about last time and they were like no no
no I don't know he didn't tell us at
Starbucks and and he said yes it was
hilarious man so I'm watching this is I
hate when guys do this I love the
manager by the way of the Houston improv
but I can't stand when people do this
like they act like they knew some [__]
before it happened when you didn't
goddamn know it's like the equivalent of
like oh yeah I like that band's first
album way better not many people know
what it is is it [__] EP so he was
like he was like I so I'm watching
Chris's stand-up and I noticed his face
get like really nervous and he's like
and he whispers to this how it you know
he's [__] first of all imagine me
getting nervous about having to go take
a [__] I don't give a [__] I literally
thought it was like a for 250 people I
was like dude I had today I'm sorry guys
I gotta take a [__]
life happens haha and then he was like
and then he whispered to me hey could
you get Jason which is [__] because
I'm holding a microphone doesn't matter
if you're whispering or not gun here
also gun no I had asked for Jason to
come up because Jason is gun come up and
they're gonna see their eyes see with
their eyes and then I gotta never get
any and then my openers were like dude
so you tried to pretend like you weren't
gonna take a [__] what did everybody
think when you came back I was like huh
and then I [__] looked at the manager
I was like yo you tried to act like I
didn't [__] own that [__] nah bro you
got the wrong [__] you got the
wrong [__] dude when I take a
[__] people know about that [__] you
[__]
and you know about it I'm taking in a
montage right here all wrong one what's
the [__] do I not have it don't BAM
boom BAM oh I got here hit the wrong key
montage of me taking shits me using one
toilet somebody going now
and using another toy something no I'm
using a golden toilet peeler like this
that's the one in a dress all right
let's take some Twitter questions do you
have some oh man one fire turning into
one eyeliner dude I hate saying this but
one fire turning into one fire
hey soos Miguel choppa Chris D'Elia do
you drink kombucha it seems like the
most khuda thing to drink dude I'll tell
you right now i straight-up don't know
what the [__] kombucha is is that the
[__] with the little balls in it
Oh boba is this [__] with the balls in
it dude [__] boba I tried that once
years ago and that's [__] nasty dude
Oh kombucha is the [__] with the seeds
in it Chia
like kombucha right that's what is Chi
is this [__] with the seeds in it what
the [__] is kombucha I don't know what
it is
Oh a fermented tea fermented but doesn't
mean [__] oh really
kombucha I'm gonna look it up is it
Japanese or something other stuff in it
yo dude hey drinks with this stuff in it
just be soup you know that shit's
annoying man oh but it's got leaves and
balls in it oh really
what is it the jungle what am i drinking
the [__] jungle
yo Oh am i drinking a but a [__]
rainforest get out of here make it
liquid make it pure [__] liquid the
only thing that's okay is orange juice
with pulp in it cuz that pulp is [__]
blasting with flavor but dude if you put
[__] in your [__] drinks can
gratulations you made soup now make the
lid wider spread it out it's a ball get
a spoon and [__] lap it up you doggy
it's so dumb dude oh but it's good
all right you kuda ah but it's good but
i RK kuda you're drinking it cuz it's an
activity that's why you're drinking it
dude
if you drink [__] cuz you're because
it's an activity you're a [__] kuda
and we don't stand for that [__] here at
the log cabin the [__] out of here man
you know I'm saying uh-oh this is a good
one
hanna de Vries i actually think of busy
I've thought about this [__] already
what do you say when you're in a public
washroom and someone knocks on the stall
door that's a creep that's what she
wrote as a creep I actually think I've
covered this but I don't know if I have
but I'll do it again dude I know you
knock on the door to the bathroom if
someone's in there once that's it do you
know why because nobody has ever wanted
to hang out in a [__] public bathroom
longer than they've needed to be so if
I'm in there for and I'm serious
35 minutes I'm [__] my brains out
and I need to be in there okay you don't
[__] come on
hey stuff is coming out of my [__]
dude let me be I got here first
trust me I don't want this to be
happening more than you don't want this
to be happening
find another restroom or [__] your pants
and a matter of fact sometimes I go you
know what I did once I was in a coffee
bean I went to this is funny actually
because it kind of it didn't backfire
but this is how someone learns and I was
taking a [__] number two and I went
to go lock the door and I noticed that
the lock wasn't really that much of a
good lock I I learn I saw that if you
really tried you could open the door but
I was like look I'll lock it as long as
it goes if somebody tries to open it
they'll see it's locked and they're not
gonna try to break it down cuz they
don't work for SWAT so I'm there sitting
down doing mmm business okay and I hear
a jiggle at the door and a knock and I
say I'm in here even though I don't need
to because the goddamn door was locked
alright so I'm sitting still going and
then I hear the jiggle again and I'm
like well this [__] gonna make
this door open if he really tries to do
that and again I say hey I don't know
what you want me to tell you but I'm
busy and I'm in here then it happens
again and I get mad I get mad because
this person isn't understanding that I'm
not throwing my 25th birthday party in
this coffee bean bathroom with piss all
over the floor I don't want to be there
alright haha I'm there because I have to
be [__] so then one last time they
jerked the door and this is by the way
not long enough they're giving me
between the jiggles and sure enough the
lock comes undone oh oh and right then I
go from angry to zero angry and absolute
I have cultivated chill mode at the
highest level I couldn't be more relaxed
if I were sleeping because I though the
the anger that I had
is realized into the love and excitement
and balanced out my anger the love
events and excitement that this person's
gonna have to see me with my pants
around my ankles and my [__] privates
on display while I'm unloading okay and
I'm happy and I'm karma [__] dude I'm as
calm as a [__] typewriter okay they
don't have emotions and in walks a
[__] twelve-year-old and I go
oh that's funny that's funny Lord that
is funny
and I mean Lord the singer because that
person is in charge of the world just as
much as Jesus Christ is maybe even more
cuz she could do some [__] the [__]
the jeff of the [__] dude going like
this in the park
cuz the Lord can lead Lord the singer
can actually do something oh the [__]
the Jeff of the guy with the hoodie
doing that in the park
dude I'm kiddin man I mean if you
believe in God that's great
believe in God all you want just you
know try to get them to change the
weather a little bit won't work no it's
all good just try to [__] just just
keep praying maybe you know I hope you
get out of debt no no it's good it's
good believe in God for real but maybe
I'll help you with car troubles or
something like that when Lord could Lord
this singer but not the Lord oh but he
does it in his own way by really what's
his own way not doing it
gotcha boi-yoi-yoing Booga welcome to
[__] Jimmy in the frog on careth 105
boi-oi-oi-oi-oing Jesus won't help you
with your car here we go
Smokey Robinson or whoever sings this
song okay forget okay forget never would
have to forget that did
it's [__] what's-his-name Michael
McDonald Michael McDonald helps the
world to play more than Jesus Christ oh
[__] dude I keep forgetting didn't
forget it huh if you heartbroken you
always remember it no it should be key
you forgetting my keys that's it that's
the song Michael McDonald's voice you
know what's the other one [__] what's
the other big one he has and then we'll
wrap up
sorry guys I'm sweating my ass off but
dude whatever I'm having a good time
this fall part guys had some ups and
downs huh oh yeah yeah wait oh that oh
yeah this one yes oh my god how did I
forget about this song used to listen
what all the time
Mike McDonald's [__] right how many guys
are named Michael McDonald you know how
much would that [__] flying suck dude
it would suck to be named the guy and
then that and then a guy gets really
famous with the same name that would
suck like if your name was LeBron James
and then LeBron James was like getting
good at basketball at 16 and you're like
[__] I'm gonna be the other LeBron James
what if your name was Keanu Reeves and
you weren't Keanu Reeves oh my god that
would [__] suck and the Internet's
not working ding ding ding ding ding
ding ding ding ding ding ding that [__]
do it that way how many notes are in
that song uh all right cool um I mean
there's a Michael McDonald that's all
it's also another Michael McDonald is
that famous in in in MADtv right all
right dude I'm out dude you have to look
up that song on your own because my
internet doesn't work one fire but
alright here we go
square cache check out the new boost
rewards program get the cash app and two
rewards code congrats get $5 give $5 -
times up get it for iOS or Android now
blue apron check out this week's menu
and get your first three meals free at
blue apron calm / Congrats
you can get merch there's new merch on
and the Mercer you got to follow the
leader tour shirts those are [__]
actually selling crazy on
my on tour they go they were sold out
before the last two shows even in in
Houston so go to the if you didn't get
one in Houston go you know my website
and get them follow the fault or you can
get tickets to the tour follow the
leader tour I'm coming to Lincoln
Nebraska Wichita Kansas in Kansas City
because City Missouri and then yeah I'm
gonna I'm gonna go up to Montreal and do
on my set I'm filming and filming for
Netflix so be ready for that you guys
are great
[Music]